l'avenir de l'humanité dont nous allons
beaucoup parler dans ce journal dépend
des progrès en matière de médecine la
première médicale qui vient d'être
réalisée à montpellier ouvre de nouveaux
horizons
l'équipe du professeur pierre rabhi chan
a implanté il ya quinze jours une puce
électronique dans le ventre d'un homme
paralysé des jambes dans deux semaines
on saura si ce procédé lui permettra de
se lever et de marcher
il faut donc rester très prudent même si
cette opération suscite déjà beaucoup
d'espoir chez les personnes
paraplégiques
correspondance le ou lamberton car
incomati il ne pourra pas faire ses
premiers pas avant une quinzaine de
jours
mais pour marc merger rendu paraplégique
il ya neuf ans après un accident voir
aujourd'hui les muscles de ses jambes de
reprendre vie les uns après les autres
est déjà un miracle
lorsqu'il ya eu la première simulation
moi c'est un moment d'émotion parce que
je voyais mes orteils j'ai les muscles
mes jambes bougeaient piste est en fait
un moment émouvant pour moi
si marc merger pourra peut-être
remarcher c'est grâce à cette puce
électronique qu'on lui implanter dans le
ventre relié à 14 électrodes de placer
sur les muscles les nerfs de ses membres
inférieurs ce sont en fait des
impulsions électriques qui donneront vie
aux jambes
l'opération baptisée lève toi et marche
est une première elle a eu lieu à
montpellier le 28 septembre dernier
on peut dire de façon certaine c'est que
chaque branche locale cgt
effectivement l'opération s'est très
bien passée et les suites opératoires
sont bonnes sur le plan technique on
peut dire aussi que l'implant a été
testé c'est une réussite d'avoir
combiner ces deux types d'élèves
maintenant le résultat final on est
obligé d'attendre avec peut-être une
points 2
de crainte partagée tous les deux dans
toute l'équipe puisque les gens de la
technologie sont aussi inquiets que nous
d'un résultat final mais ça c'est ça la
surprise qui persuadé sera bonne ce qui
rassure l'équipe médicale c'est que en
emmenant le principe a été testé avec
succès en fa sont les électrodes sur la
peau de marc merger et même si tous les
paraplégiques ne pourront pas bénéficier
du projet lève toi et marche
si dans quinze jours l'opération se
révèle être un succès ce sera un
formidable espoir pour beaucoup de
personnes handicapées